we have another one of these stories of
what at this point I mean I don't know
if we just have to call this finding out
the hard way another anti-vaccine
Republican this one in particular was
pushing the big lie that Donald Trump
actually won the 2020 election but it
was stolen by Joe Biden I mean it's like
exhausting to even repeat it at this
point
um a local Michigan Republican official
Republican official reports The Daily
Beast who refused to certify Joe Biden's
presidential victory in his County
and who open very much opposed vaccines
has died of covet 19. this was 63 year
old William Hartman he we now found out
died on November 30th in a hospital in
Michigan he would regularly spread lies
and conspiracy theories about the
election on of course his Facebook page
and
um a fellow Republican on the Wayne
County Board of canvassers initially
declined to certify the tallies of the
2020 presidential election votes after
they come in and uh Hartman agreed with
that and tried also to prevent their
certification and uh ultimately they did
certify the vote counts then they said
we're going to take back our
certification some of you may remember
like we talked about this in Michigan
where there was a certification and then
they wanted to take it back but it was
too late on and on and on this same guy
William Hartman said on Facebook that
vaccine passports resemble Nazi
Germany's Draconian laws and he has
continued with this incredible string of
completely Bonkers coveted vaccine
denial and conspiracy theories and other
things and he ended up in the hospital
with the virus and he has subsequently
died we learned that he was in the ICU
uh with pneumonia
and on and on and on so at this point
are these stories unique they are not
um is this at the end of the day
finding out the hard way
we knew what to do
we knew how to do it
the vaccine was free to him
and he didn't get it now with any
individual case and this is always the
important thing you will have people who
will come back and say but David can you
say for sure that if this particular
individual had been vaccinated he would
have survived and of course not nobody
is saying that what we do know is that
being vaccinated dramatically
reduces the odds that you end up very
very sick or dying and at a population
level
not necessarily William Hartman but at
the population level we know what there
is to do and part of this you know I I
hesitate to use this term but there's a
very specific way in which it makes
sense these unvaccinated covet deaths
when these are just choices not to get
vaccinated often because of false
beliefs about the vaccine
these are wasted that these are
pointless deaths and what I mean by that
is
if you didn't do the simple thing that
would likely prevent you from dying not
guaranteed but likely you didn't do it
then it's very stupid to die in this way
in the sense that just getting a free
vaccine might have kept you alive now of
course there are people who do all of
the things that are available they they
follow various guidelines they get
vaccinated and sadly they still get sick
and die Colin Powell is one of them
that's a different situation and of
course because we know that that will
happen to some people why would we want
to add on to that by tempting Fate by
saying I'm not going to go and get
vaccinated it makes no sense in that
particular sense it's a dumb death and
it doesn't mean that getting covet is
feminine The Way Tucker said it just
means if you've not done the basics
which are free
to give yourself a better shot at
staying alive if you get this disease
then you're sort of learning the hard
way now the last thing and I've said
this before I'll say it again this is
not merely a self-resolving problem we
can look away from what I mean by that
is as we've said before if this is just
as simple as only the unvaccinated will
die
as a result of them not getting
vaccinated we could look away and say
it's sad but at the end of the day uh
it's your own funeral but it's a
contagious disease and we don't know how
many people did William Hartman infect
maybe some were too young to get
vaccinated maybe some were vaccinated
but were very sick so in getting covered
and dying how many other people might he
have taken down with him and of course
we don't know the answer but that's the
reason why we can't simply look away and
say well who cares if anyone gets
vaccinated I did and I'm I'm now
protected and it's as simple as that it
is a communicable disease and the
behavior of these people affects others
as well so tack another one onto the
list notable anti-vaxx Republican pushed
vaccine conspiracies pushed election
conspiracies now dead of covid